starts with war whether it's a hot War
whether it's a cold war whether it's a
proxy war but the reality is uh
something needs to be done Iran needs to
be dealt with so if it's a direct
conflict with Iran nobody's looking for
that other than Lindsey Graham or Nicki
haly nobody wants that but I think we
understand that Iran is the tip of the
spear okay that's option a option number
two proxy wars whether it's the houthis
in the Red Sea whether it's Hamas in
Gaza who is funded by Iran
whether it's Hezbollah your old friends
in in Lebanon tell them I say hello my
head on a platter by the way exactly I'm
sure or the old you know option three
economic sanctions so either
way the old peace through strength thing
we we cannot simply sit idly by and
allow these people these terrorists
regimes authoritarian regimes to just do
what they want